hello everyone
thank you all for coming
so my name is mark seaman and
you can probably tell uh if you want to
know more about me there's information
that blocked uploaded dks i'm not going
to tie you with any of that
um so
this talk is called fractal architecture
as it says on the slide and before i
dive into you know the next slide i
think it's it's a good idea to just
establish what um what sort of problem
that this um presentation addresses
so uh this this presentation addresses
the problem of um software development
productivity i think most of us you know
probably have the experience that we
would like
um software development to be
more productive you know to happen
faster to be more you know um responsive
to
to user requirements and things like
that so that's you know this this is
generally the idea you know it seems
like we're not really doing um we could
we could probably do better with
software development productivity and
and this talk tries to address that this
problem i'm not saying this is the only
solution but i think it's a fairly
important one
so why is software development
productivity not as good as we would
like it to be
and
i think one of the reasons is that we
spend a lot of time
reading existing code we actually
struggle to
to read the existing code and robert c
martin agrees with me one of his book
books is writing the ratio of time spent
reading versus writing is well over 10
to one
and you know i don't know where he gets
that number from i think it's just he's
just using it to illustrate a point
but at least i can accept with the with
you know the general idea that there's a
lot of reading going on you know you
struggle with understanding what
existing code bases do
in order to figure out you know what's
the next line of code that i have to
write
so if this is true
there's an opportunity for you know
quite
massive
productivity improvement right there so
we can try to illustrate this by you
know just lining you know a couple of
boxes off so here's you know 10 orange
boxes and one green box the orange boxes
represent the all the reading you have
to do of existing code and then the
green box
represents the writing of new code so
that's a ten to one ratio
now often when people talk about you
know development productivity you'll
have you know software wind vendors who
will um who will tell you that if you
use their new tools their new
development environments whatever that
is you will improve productivity or you
know language designers will tell you
that if you use a new language that will
improve your productivity your
frameworks will improve your
productivity
and most of those productivity gains are
framed in the context of enabling you to
write code faster
now just hypothetic hypothetically if
you imagine that you had a tool that
could magically slice the amount of time
you have to write new code in half that
is not realistic but just let's imagine
that you know a that would look like
this so this would be you know
a reduction in time it takes to write
code about by 50
so 50 sounds like quite a bit of an
improvement in productivity but really
it's just you know for 4.5 percent
so
and you know don't get me wrong i i'll
take all the productivity gains that i
can can get wherever i can so if there's
some you know vendor who you know
presents to me a better development
environment that you know enables me to
move a little bit faster than i could
before i'll take it
but i just you know i think we should be
under no illusion that that's not really
where we kind of harvest the big
improvements in productivity
on the other hand if we can just slice
off you know one of those boxes in in
terms of you know being able to read
code
that's that's a much bigger improvement
in productivity so
it really um it would really be
favorable if we start you know
thinking about writing code that also
reads easily and take you know be very
explicit about that because that's where
improvements
develop you know productivity
improvements are actually to be found
um so so how do we do that so the the
problem is you know every i think
everyone can agree that we should write
you know readable code it's just that
often if if you leave it at that you you
basically have what sounds like a
subjective discussion it sounds like a
matter of opinion you know some people
will say i find this code readable and
then someone else will say i don't find
this readable at all i think it sucks
and then the first person will say but
it's very readable i wrote it and then
the next person will say yeah that's why
it's not readable so you can't have
those sorts of discussions right it's
it's opinion based it's subjective that
doesn't work
so instead we need to figure out you
know can we somehow make it a little bit
more
actionable a little bit more concrete
can we make it a little bit more
objective i'm not going to you know
promise you that it'll be 100 objective
it will not i'm just trying to pull in
that direction
so in order to write readable code we
should probably start to you know just
try to understand
what actually happens in the brain when
we're trying to read code and you know
i'm not a neuroscientist or anything and
no one really knows anyway but we can
have some you know large picture
explanations or you know descriptions of
you know what happens when we read code
so i'm going to show you some code and
i'm going to talk quite a bit up about
this code
and
what what's important here is how we
approach reading code so even though i'm
going to spend quite some time you know
talking about this little code snippet
here it's not because i want you to
understand the algorithm
i want you i want to talk about you know
what happens when we read it
so that's the important part so i would
claim
that this is readable code
not because i wrote it and not because
it's nicely formatted maybe you think it
is maybe you disagree
but because of other reasons but let's
let's start to you know think about you
know what what happens if we read code
so um
so first of all i think we you know most
of us start from the top and go go down
so you say okay this is a method called
allocate uh it takes some reservations
as input i don't really know what you
know reservation is but
maybe i can figure that out later it
returns iron mobile of table i don't
really know what table is either but i
can probably figure that out if
that turns out to be important so all
the um all the code that you see in this
talk is taken from my book code that
fits in your head and it's my patented
you know online
restaurant reservation system example
that i always use
um it's not patented it's just something
i said um
so um so after you figure that out you
just move on and you say okay so here's
an object we we take some tables we turn
it into a list a list of something in in
dot net so this is c sharp code a list
of something is a is a collection of
things that can change you can add more
things to it you can remove things from
it you can sort it and you know do
various different things to clear it out
all together um so it might change state
and if we're trying to understand what's
going on that's probably a good idea to
just keep in mind you know when we read
the rest of the code because maybe the
state of this allocation will have some
impact on how the code executes turns
out not to be the case here but you know
it might you don't know until you
actually read through the code
so there's one thing to sort of keep
track of in your head so basically
what's happening here is you're running
a little emulator you're running a
little c-sharp interpreter that
interprets the code and you're not on
the computer but in your brain and
you're sort of trying to figure out okay
what would happen if various different
things so for example you might say in
the next line uh with the for each thing
you might say well what would happen if
reservations is empty in that case you
would just drop all the way through and
return the allocation but you're still
keeping track of you know um you know
what's the state of allocation you know
what's the state of that collection
now on the other hand you would you
might also imagine in your brain when
you're reading the code okay so what's
going to happen if the if that
connection is not empty if if we have
some reservations in in which case the
code sort of takes a different pathway
through the through the
and the code there um
and then you know there's a this thing
where we try to find a table in that
allocation
and again there's a branch there's a
decision to be made so
that that little thing
if table is curly brackets that's a c
sharp sort of a little pun expression
that basically means if table is
something as opposed to null
so when we're trying to find the table
it might be null and if it's null if
it's not something um again nothing more
is going to happen so on the other hand
if we find a table that fits uh the
desired quantity we um we now go and and
modify that allocation collection we
remove the table but then we add it back
just you know with the reservations you
know associated to it so we reserve the
table so that um to that particular
reservation
yeah
so um so this is not hard to follow and
and you'd say well okay so even though
we have some state mutation going on in
that you know one object that we sort of
kept track of in our head um we we now
understand that even though it changes
throughout you know these loop at least
the number of tables stay the same
because we always you know first remove
and then add something back in so it's
the same number all the time
so there's quite a there's at least two
types of quantification going on here or
you know attempts at you know making
things a little bit more concrete we'll
i've counted the number of pathways
through the system this is called
cyclomatic complexity and you can say
well it's it's a way of thinking about
you know the various different pathways
to the system but you can also think
about it as this as it's basically three
parallel universes where you know the
code might take one or three uh pathways
through and you sort of have to fit
those three options those three parallel
you know universes in your brain at the
same time in order to understand what's
actually happening here
um
and then you
you you need to keep track of at least
one thing because allocation might
change state and you know in this case
it turns out that it doesn't impact you
know the execution it doesn't make any
any impact on decisions but you know you
didn't know before you actually read
through the code
so i would say this code fits in your
head because there's not too much going
on there's sort of three pathways and
there's you know basically one mutable
variable that you need to keep track of
and that's not too much now so the next
question is you know what is too much
what's the threshold if i say one is
fine if i say three is fine you know
when when does it become not fine you
know is uh is 10 still readable if we
had
20 things going on would that be
readable
and i would say the threshold is around
seven
and
this goes back to a results from
experimental psychology there's a paper
by george a miller from 1956 called the
magical number seven plus minus two
you've probably heard about it and it's
one of those few results from
experiments in psychology that actually
seems to be fairly robust so so miller
did a lot of experiments with the with
the with subjects where he asked people
to remember you know all sorts of things
you know numbers and things like that
and
he found out that most people could keep
track of about seven things and then if
if he asked them to keep track of much
more than that they started to forget
some of the things that um that were not
as
as present in their memory
so
so in general you know miller asked
people to remember all sorts of numbers
but you also ask them to remember other
things so for example you know names of
colors or or things like that and he
just called that information those
information he called them chunks the
chunks of information
now i'm just gonna switch over here and
start a little um
animation while i'm still talking i'm
just going to keep talking then so the
problem is with the software development
is that you know if you write a
completely brand new code base and you
start with hello world there might
actually just be that one thing going on
but you know
you know as you add more features and
more
things that the software can do to your
code base there's going to be more and
more things that you need to keep track
of
so
so in a realistic code base there's
there's more than seven things going on
that's probably seven thousand things
going on seven million things going on
in a realistic code base uh and that
doesn't fit in your short-term memory
um so so we need to figure out you know
how do we deal with that sort of problem
so so the reason why i started this
little animation is as you can tell it
uh it's it's just keeps on adding chunks
um the chunks appear randomly every
second or so and they appear you know on
the outside of the screen so either to
the left or the right or the top of the
bottom and you will also notice that
these chunks sort of try to
arrange themselves so that they try to
keep as much distance to each other as
possible but we just keep adding more
just like we we would you know if we
start in a new code base we would keep
adding more and more decision points
more and more things that you know in
order to understand what the code does
we would
you know we would have to keep that
track of that as well so
we don't structure the code in the way
where we don't we don't just start with
a main method and then just you know
write a main method that just runs
forever we structure code in various
different ways by dividing it into
objects that communicate with each other
you know routine
you know functions that call each other
and so on um
but one of the things we need to figure
out is you know what's a good way of
structuring code so that it you know
remains readable
so that it fits in our short-term memory
even though there's you know it's not
only seven things but there's maybe
seven thousand things and you can see
yeah you know
i'm not going to reach 7000 things out
of 7 million things here i'm not that's
not really what i'm waiting for but you
know you just keep on adding and more
and more stuff so we need to figure out
you know how to structure code so that
we respect that cognitive constraint
that
that our memories have
uh i remember you know once i was um
i was
talking to a person yeah i was engaged
with a client that had a legacy code
base and i got the chance to talk to
some of the developers on that legacy
code base and and i asked one of the
the newest member of the team i asked
him
uh so how much time did it take you
before you felt that you were able to
work in this code base on your own on
you know independently of of your
colleagues and he said it took me three
months before i actually felt confident
to work on this code base on my own
so when you have you know legacy code
basis like that there's a lot of stuff
going on
and the
strategy you'll take when you try to
learn a code base like that it that does
not employ short-term memory so so this
developer who took three months in order
to be you know to be able to work with
that code base
he
probably painstakingly started to commit
the structure of this code base to his
long-term memory which is a completely
different game but the problem with you
know relying on your long-term memory
instead of your short-term memory is
that first of all it's it takes a long
time so that's why we spend so much time
always reading code because we have to
engage our long-term memory and it's
much slower and also you have the
problem with long-term memory that you
know once you've committed something to
long-term memory it's hard to get rid of
again and that means if you've you know
committed the structure of the code base
to long-term memory and then you go
change it
um then the what you've learned about
the structure of the large gate code
base
no longer really applies and then you
sort of have to unlearn it again which
is also difficult now short-term memory
on the other hand is much more efficient
in this way because if you if you learn
something and you keep track of
something in your short-term memory you
work with that and once you're done with
that you basically just forget about it
and the next time you look at something
you just basically load it into
short-term memory again look at it and
forget about it again
now as you probably noticed you know the
the um these blobs these chunks that
just keep on adding here they sort of
try to they they sort of start to form
such a honeycomb pattern a hexagonal
grid so if we wanted to pick out just
seven of those
um
we would have a shape that looks pretty
much like this one
so i call this a hex flower
i think it looks a little bit like a
stylized flower in the sense you have
you know six petals and in the center of
the flower
but what i'm going to use this for is
it's just a
symbol of you know our short-term memory
capacity because we have seven cells
there so you can imagine that those are
registers where we can you know we can
each register can hold one chunk of
information and we can hold about seven
of those again um
i know that it's seven plus minus two uh
and this diagram doesn't allow nine um
but this is not you know again this is
not a hard thing it's not science it's
more like you know and a way of
illustrating a point
and it's pretty
um
we we also need to realize that you know
if we're looking at code there's a lot
of abstraction going on so inside of
each of those cells
there's probably going to be more stuff
going on
so
if we structure the code in such a way
that there's at most seven things going
on we can structure the code so that it
fits in our short-term memory but again
we we
we should probably realize that you know
if we're thinking about layers of
abstraction you know each of those cells
will again contain some more code that
does something else so you can keep on
zooming into one of the cells and maybe
you know finally you'll find a piece of
code like this one so this is um
i chose this create method this this is
sitting on a repository class that
communicates with a relational database
and actually saves you know reservations
into the database and i chose this one
because this is about as
much as you can zoom in in terms of
layers of abstraction there's really
nothing there's no more layers of
abstraction hidden behind this code not
in terms of user code anyway because
there's still framework code there's sql
connection sql command and things like
that but there's not really a lot of of
you know my own code so this is sort of
like as granular as it gets in terms of
you know levels of detail so we could
ask ourselves again is this code
readable
and instead of being you know
opinion-based what we wanted to do is to
say let's try to quantify it not because
we want to turn it into science but just
you know be able to have a you know a a
discussion that is a little bit less
opinionated and a little bit more about
you know some facts that we can actually
bring to bed and you know discuss things
about so we could ask ourselves for
example what's the cyclomatic complexity
here how many different pathways do we
have
and there's only two because you know
either you immediately um you know exit
throwing an argument null exception or
you run through the rest of the code so
um
cyclomatic complexity of two that's
that's okay if we think about cyclomatic
complexity as representing sort of
parallel parallel dimensions of of the
code you know two is not you know that's
not a lot if we can keep track of seven
um
we could also ask ourselves something
else if you remember one other thing i
talked about is
i talked about you know when we read
code we sort of run a little emulator of
the you know of the language inside our
head and we try to keep track of state
so what we can do is we can try to count
the objects that are involved in this
method because you know
in a in an unsophisticated naive way of
counting this
everything
um is a priori something that may change
state and then we can become a little
bit more sophisticated later on so so
let's try to just you know count objects
to see how much how many things how many
chunks are involved in in a little code
snippet like this
um so there's the restaurant id that's
one object one one parameter there's
reservation that's two we have a thing
called connection string and it's you
know in this code snippet it's not too
it's not you can't tell exactly where
that comes from but that's a read only
property it's a string
now
if if
some of you are not sharp developers a
property is just a glorified class field
so just think of this as a read-only
class field that's basically what it is
and it's a string so this just contains
the information about how do we connect
to the database and we use that to
create a con object a connection object
i'm just counting things here there's
also something called create reservation
sql this is another string this is not
even a read-only property this is a
constant string it's just the the actual
sql you know the t sequel you know
language that that's going to be applied
to this to the server when we run this
command
um so
another string
and we use that to create a command
object and then that's actually it
there's no more you know objects
involved the rest is just you know
manipulating those objects
so there are six things and again you
know if if our memory capacity is seven
that's just about it we we're good
um so again this is a way you can
discuss you know for example if you're
discussing with colleagues you know
is this is this method getting too
complicated should we you know split it
up into two helper methods or things
like that and you say well what's the
criteria and when do we start splitting
things up when do we start refactoring
and i would say you start refactoring
when when when some of those
quantification mechanisms begins to
indicate that the code is becoming too
complicated
and seven is quite a low threshold but
it actually enables you to keep the code
fairly fresh and clean if you if you go
with you know that sort of threshold
so um if we want to be a little more
sophisticated you might then argue and
you might say well okay so that's all
fine but you know if you take you know
for example the restaurant id the one
label one that's an int
and you don't need to keep track of you
know an int in if you're trying to
remember or keep you know running this
little emulator in your brain you don't
you don't have to keep track of you know
what restaurant id might you know change
into because it's an immutable value
it's not going to change
so immutable values are really nice for
that particular reason so they don't
really tax your memories that much
because it can't change
so this the same thing goes for strings
so connection string and create
reservation sequel those labels three
and five those are strings they're also
immutable.net which means they can't
really change either uh so you don't
really have to worry too much about you
know might this one object change state
while you know the code executes it will
not it is immutable
so that that's actually like three out
of six things that are not really gonna
tax your memory
so you say well okay that actually turns
out that immutability is a really nice
thing in terms of readability
because that means we don't really need
to worry about them changing state
we should do more of that
and i did so it turns out if you go and
look at this code base and look at you
know reservation the one label two this
is a custom domain class that i wrote
but i wrote it so that it's a value
object it's an immutable uh data
structure so also it's not gonna change
states so really the only two things
that might change state in this code is
just the connection and the command just
two things and you can see that actually
happens you know just uh below
you know after the um we created the
command we start adding you know binding
parameters to it so it actually mutates
six times but it's easy to follow
because it's sort of doing the same
thing over over and over again and then
in the last the in the pronunciable line
there we open the connection so the
connection changes state as well
but it's it's easy enough to follow
because even if you want to be
unsophisticated there's only six things
going on and in reality there's only
really two things you need to keep track
of
so if the
memory limit is seven then we're all
good so we can enumerate the um the
objects in this way or we can you know
try to assign them you know each to one
of those cells that we have in our
short-term memory and we say okay so we
have room for seven and this is only six
that fits in our head
so
again you can think of this little
figure this little hex flower as just a
symbol for things that fit in your head
so i started by showing you the lowest
level of detail i showed you this create
method where there's not a lot of you
know extra you know abstraction hiding
behind that create method it just talks
to the the you know relational database
sdk
but then you you might probably say well
but there's there's going to be code
that calls that create method that we
just looked at
and that code is probably going to call
some other methods as well that have you
know some some moving parts inside of it
so
doesn't that mean that you know those
that complexity that is inside the
create method and the complexity that's
inside some of these other methods
doesn't it mean that those things are
going to compound so you know it's fine
enough you know if you're at the lowest
level of detail um but what if you are
at a higher level of detail then then
how do you deal with that
and the thing is you know again our
memory constraint you know the way the
cognitive constraints that we have in
our brain is not going to change it's
seven
so we have to sort of work within that
boundary and figure figure out ways to
do that so even if we if we zoom out and
say okay so now i'm looking at things
from a higher you know level of
abstraction we still need to respect
that we have this cognitive constraint
the brain is not going to change anytime
soon
regardless of what you know
kurzweil is believing i don't think
that's going to happen
so we should be able to zoom out and
zoom out and zoom out and we should we
should be able to zoom out all the way
to for example the entry point of the
application and even if we look at that
it should fit in our brains if we you
know we should understand we should be
able to go
to be able to understand what's going on
at a high level of abstraction uh you
know in our short term memory so if
you've ever seen asp.net code this is
basically just generated by wizard i
didn't write this code but still you you
know you might want to count you know is
there does this actually fit in your
head and it turns out it's actually
pretty simple um all the all the
interesting stuff happens in the startup
method we can look at that at the moment
so there's really only three things
going on there's only three objects
involved
so that's will within capacity so that's
that's that's fine
the point here being that if you want to
look at you know what happens in the
startup class though um
at all levels of distractions we should
respect the cognitive constraints of our
brain so when i look at the start of
class it should be structured in such a
way that there's at most seven things
going on and that also means
startup should be independent of arcs
and web builder you know when i go and
look at startup i shouldn't have to also
remember that there's there are things
like arcs and web builder so we can
start by looking at just the public api
of the startup class and we can say okay
so by convention there's these two
configure methods um there's a
constructor that takes an eye
configuration value that sort of like
those things go together so again if we
if we want to enumerate them in that way
that's good you know again at that level
of abstraction it's understandable
um and then if we want to look at
configure services we can go and and
start to examine that and again if you
want to do a little bit of a
quantification and say well is this
readable you know meaning does this fit
in your head
we can start to again quantify it and
say well what for example what what's
the cyclomatic complexity here and
there's no branching there's no looping
there's just one straight line through
the code
so cyclomatic complexity is one i know
you can't see all the code it goes a
little bit beyond here i'm gonna scroll
in a moment but i promise there's no
surprises there
so cyclomatic complexity of one it
doesn't get any better than that what if
we start counting the um the objects
again just like we did the last time
um so i'm not going to you know do that
you know
quite as detailed and analysis as i did
the last time but you notice there are
six things involved
so again we're good
it fits in our in our short-term memory
this is still a very high level of
abstraction so you're getting a little
bit more detail about how the software
is structured so again the point here is
not i'm not trying to teach you how i
wrote the code i'm trying to teach you
how to structure code so that it becomes
discoverable and it's you know it's
readable um so if you're in if you're
trying to sort of figure figure out you
know how do things work in this
particular code base for example let's
say you're interested in knowing you
know how what are the security
mechanisms do i need to log on into this
system in order to you know to to use it
you probably say well maybe i can find
some information there and configure
authorization
and and then if you go there your
expectation should be that again you
know that code is structured so that
there's at most seven things going on
and all the stuff that you're looking at
right now should now you know go out of
scope basically you shouldn't have to
you shouldn't have to know about any of
this stuff that we're looking at at the
moment and if you want to know about you
know how does persistence work uh you
might say well we could also go and look
at configure repository that sounds like
a place where i could get a little bit
more information about that and then
again if you go to and look at that you
know what happens inside of configure
authorization for example should become
irrelevant
um
so here's another way we can just this
is a little bit more of an ad hoc
quantification but the point is that you
know things you should structure code so
that you know you always have this you
know this appropriate level of this
appropriate amount of information uh at
the level of abstraction that you're
looking
so so one thing you might wonder now is
i sort of hinted at this before
uh
there's this remaining problem of saying
okay so but if we have
at the lower level of abstraction if we
have something like the create method
where there's you know six things you
know six objects being activated and
cyclomatic complexity of two that's not
too bad but then if we compose those you
know methods with other things that also
have you know moving parts
what prevents those things from
compounding so that instead of which you
know we're only having six things going
on we have you know 18 or 25 or 100
things going on um
we we really need to be able to you know
let those things that you know at one
level of abstraction have something
going on you know when we look at it
from the higher level of abstraction
they should just you know present as one
thing we should be able to think of them
as a chunk of information not several
chunks of information but just one thing
so the question is how do you do that
and and the high level answer to that is
good api design um
and there are lots of you know they're
thick big thick books about you know how
do you do good api design and all of
them have you know most of them have
pretty good
recommendations about that but i want to
do something a little bit more concrete
here
so i'm going to look at
one particular method
and i will claim and i will now make the
argument that this
not only fits in your brain we're going
to look at the allocate method
i'll make the argument that not only
will does this fit in your brain sort of
already been there but there was oh i
will also you know make the argument
that when we look at it from the outside
this presents as one chunk of
information one chunk of information and
only one chunk even though there's
actually more stuff going on so we did
establish that we have a cyclomatic
complexity of three
and um we also did establish that we
have some stuff going on actually
actually if you want to count all the
all the things that are involved there's
actually six um six objects but there's
only one of them that has mutant that
that has the potential to to mutate but
if we want to be unsophisticated we
could say there's six things going on
and at least also a cyclomatic
complexity of three so we can't really
afford any of this complexity to escape
this abstraction scope that we're
looking at so at this level of detail
it's fine we can deal with it but if
we're looking at the allocate method
from the outside we can't allow you know
stuff like this this these
implementation details to escape because
if we have to keep track of all of those
six things plus we know whatever happens
in other method calls it's not going to
fit in our head it's not going to fit in
our short-term memory so we we need a
way to figure out that this collapses
into being just one chunk of information
one abstraction
and i will make the argument that that's
the case here why is that it's because
i've very deliberately written this
method so that it has some properties
that are very desirable so first of all
it has no side effects
some of you will already know where i'm
going with this
let's just go back and look at that it
has no side effects and what's a side
effect the side effect is something that
changes the observable state of the
universe
so if you send an email that's a side
effect if you add a road to the database
that's a side effect if you repaint the
screen on your computer that's a side
effect basically you can't do anything
interesting with a computer without
producing side effects so it's not that
we don't like side effects but we just
want to be very deliberate about where
we put them and we want to avoid them
most of the places but when this one
doesn't send email it doesn't um it
doesn't you know add rows to the
database it doesn't it doesn't write to
the console it doesn't write to disk it
there isn't there are no side effects
here so it's a side effect free method
so that's one property and that's a nice
property all all by itself now when i
say property here i mean quality trade
you know uh characteristic of of the
code
now another property that this method
has is that it's deterministic you know
for the same inputs it's always going to
return the same output
there's no
randomness going on here it's there's no
random object there's no access to the
system clock we're not asking about your
date time now or anything's like like
that we're not you know
doing anything uh that might introduce
some sort of non-determinism we're not
you know reading from the console we're
not querying uh you know um
third-party web services or anything
like that we're not even querying a
database we're just making calculations
we're this is an algorithm
so it's side effect free and it has
it is deterministic and we have a name
for that that's a pure function
and
the interesting thing about pure
functions is that they are what we call
referentially transparent so that's a
big word but what does that mean
so referentially transparent that means
that a function call is equal to its
result
so think about how you do arithmetic you
probably learned to memorize the
multiplication table when you went to
school when you were kids
so if if someone asks you you know what
is 4 times 5 you just say well that's 20
it is 20 right i'm really really bad at
this
and but what you don't do is you you you
don't actually perform the calculation
because how do you calculate
4 times 5 well you take 5 and you say 5
plus 5 plus 5 plus 5 and you can add
them together that's actually the
calculation but that's not what you do
you just memorized the result
and and you can do that because
you know multiplication is also a pure
function and it means you don't have to
perform the calculation if you know what
the result is that's just as good so you
don't have to run the function if you
already know the result so trans
referential transparency means that the
function call and the result that
produces are equivalent you know
conceptually and also cognitively we can
think of them as being the same thing
so this means if you have something like
allocate here what's the result well
it's an iron mobile of table then you
know it's a collection of tables
and and you can think of that as just
being one chunk of information so if you
want to look at the allocate method from
the next
level of abstraction up
it just collapses into being a value
it's a collection of tables we don't
care that it's actually a calculation
with you know with some
execution steps it's just a value and
because of referential transparency we
know that this is true
so
functions
are awesome
do more of those
um it doesn't mean that you that you can
completely avoid you know having side
effects and non-deterministic code and
all sorts of things like that um but the
more you can sort of put you know the
things that are not pure functions in
very specific places and be very
deliberate about how you structure that
code uh then for the rest of the um the
code if you can keep that as pure
functions you know that all of that is
gonna you know
collapse well into just the result value
so they're going to be you know they
abstract much better in terms of code
that fits in your head
right
so again i want to reiterate that you
know at all levels of abstraction we
need to respect the constraints that
that our brains actually have
so we should be able to zoom in
and again at that new level of detail
that should be at most seven things
going on we should be able to zoom out
and you know at that level of detail and
even at the entry point there should be
at most seven things going on
all right um
let's zoom in again
because i like this animation
all right so so so again
here's another way to to um to
illustrate the same point so i know i'm
saying the same thing but you know the
illustration is going to be slightly
different here so at any given level of
abstraction we know that we have to
respect our cognitive constraint that
can be at most seven things going on
we also understand that you know behind
each of those cells there might be more
complexity hiding it's just being
abstracted away and one way to abstract
that away is by using pure functions but
there are other you know principles of
api design that also enable you to
abstract things away so that that
that they look like one thing
uh the composite design pattern for
example might do that for you as well
um
so
another way to diagram that to
illustrate that is to say well you know
at one level of abstraction we have
seven things going on but we also
understand that at the next level of
abstraction there might be up to seven
things going on in each of those sevens
in each of those seven cells so you know
at the next level down that might be up
to 49 things going on not that that fits
in our health head but we understand
that that's the case
but then we also understand that in each
of those 49 cells there might be up to
seven things going on and so forth and
so forth
so that's a fractal
and uh if you if now if you came and you
thought fractal architecture and you
were expecting something with mental
broad sets and so on you might be a
little bit disappointed say that's not
really a fact so um
and and if you don't think so then let
me give you something else this is
called a snowflake and it sort of
follows the same principle where we
start with a very simple uh you know
geometric uh structure and then we
keep on subdividing each of those
straight lines into something that looks
like that and you can keep on zooming in
on on the edge of the snowflake and
and you know if you if you render as you
as you zoom in you can keep on seeing
the same
you know structure
repeating itself over and over again
infinitely deep
and the same thing is true here you know
you can keep on assuming so i stopped
the rendering at four levels at four
layers because if i add a fifth layer
basically just because once one big
green blob you know it you can't really
see the laziness of it anymore so so
this was just for uh you know aesthetic
reasons that i stopped rendering uh
there
but um
but but you could you know contin
conceivably you could keep on
zooming into these uh you know hexagons
indefinitely and you would be able to
always subdivide them into seven more uh
hexagons so that's a fractal so that's
why i call it fractal architecture and
also just because it sounds cool
so the point being uh you know
we need to respect the
constraints that our brains have you
know in the short term memory we we can
only keep track of seven things you know
long-term memory is a different thing
but long-term memory relying too much of
relying exclusively on long-term memory
in terms of working with code bases i
believe that that's where you know it
leads us to the point where we spend we
waste too much time reading existing
code because it's really difficult to
understand
so i've been trying to write code that
has you know that is composed of
lots of very small functions and i've
done this for years and i find that it's
a it you know it's not a magic thing but
it it really gives you it makes a great
difference in terms of how readable and
how understandable the code turns out to
be so understanding this cognitive
constraints allows us to write code that
fits in our head so which is also the
title of my new book you know code that
fits in your head and you can get it
wherever good books are sold
um
so that's basically what i what i had in
terms of a presentation but i know i
also have some time left still so i and
i did that this deliberately
because i'm happy to take questions and
do some answers or answer those
questions so what i also did is i
actually brought a copy of the book
code that fits in your head it's right
here
i also bought a copy of my previous book
dependency injection principles patterns
and practices no principles practice
essa and patterns i can't remember the
the order of it that stephen dersen and
i wrote a couple of years ago and i also
brought an old t-shirt and all to fix
the t-shirt if anyone is interested in
that and i plan on giving them away to
people who ask good questions so
basically i'm just saying well the first
person who asked a question gets one of
those things and so on and if you're
asking mark what's your favorite color
that counts as a question but you don't
earn a book from you
ask a good question right um so any
questions
yes
right so the question is if you couldn't
hear it in the back if you're writing in
c sharp or basically any other
mainstream language how do you signal to
all the other programmers around out
there that you know this is actually a
pure function um you should you know you
should you know understand that this is
a pure function and the short answer is
um
there's no technical way of doing that
in shop or in java or on any other
mainstream language so you have to rely
on some sort of out-of-band
communication so either put a comment on
it or just talk to people and say this
is pure or or whatever else
if you're interested
i actually wrote a um i did write a blog
post about that so let's let's find that
i think i can find my blog here um so
what did i call that though
oh bloody hell i can't remember maybe i
can search myself okay so uh i'm not
going to spend too much time on this
let's see i don't know
uh okay i can't remember i you know i'll
i'll
um i'll put it on are you are you
looking at the slack channel for the um
for this session here if if you are i'll
i'll find it and i'll post it on the
slack channel does that work for you
because i can't remember the title right
now okay sorry about that um but um
but so but the slightly longer
answer to that is still that um let's
see let's start this up again
the um the way that these languages are
designed they um you sort of need to at
least the experience we have from
haskell haskell is one of those
languages that actually just does
distinguish between pure and impure and
it's built into the language in a very
specific way and it's something that is
very hard to retro fit into other
languages you sort of need to design it
in from the start
so
there have been attempts to use
attributes you know where you can put a
little pure on top of it but you don't
get any sort of compiler
checks on it so it's really you're
really on the honor system anyway but i
think it's a good question which one of
those things would you like
two books and a t-shirt and the t-shirt
is a little
which one which one
right okay so congratulations for that
you
yeah it's not a draw but you know i i
think my publisher likes me to give
these things away because it makes it
more desirable so now you didn't get it
you have to buy it
yes
[Music]
each sir
they shouldn't know of each other
[Music]
right okay so if i if i understand you
correctly you're saying well trunks
shouldn't know of each other um so um
so how do i keep things separate but you
know the there's probably still going to
be dependencies but you know between
things you know you can't write
everything so that they're sort of
standalone sometimes you need to
leverage you know other things
um and i think it's it's uh if i may be
so bold i think it's a little bit of a
misrepresentation of what i said because
that's not quite what i had in mind i'm
just saying whenever you look at a piece
of code there should be
few enough things going on at in that
piece of code that you can understand
you know that it fits in your short-term
memory
but you know if the three of those
things are somehow connected to each
other that's that's the thing you'll be
able to understand if there's
you know not a lot of other things going
on
but then if you mean
maybe you mean by your question is
saying well okay so if i have one thing
but that actually cause it has a lot of
dependencies that calls into other
things is that what you had in mind
but then again you know this is why i
think you know often uh pure functions
save you because again
you know even you can have you can have
a pure function that cause other pure
functions that cause other pure
functions and maybe if you try to
uh you know
if you try to summarize all the
complexity that's going on in on inside
of that you know
you know top pure function you might
have cyclomatic complexity that is you
know several hundreds of things but
still because it's referentially
transparent it just collapses into its
results so you can think of it as
equivalent to the output that it
produces so you don't really have to
worry about um
[Music]
you know how it arrived at that
conclusion and which dependencies it had
it doesn't really matter at a higher
level of abstraction
does that answer your question
okay would you like a book or a t-shirt
not at that one no
you will take the t-shirt okay
all right so um so the t-shirt has never
been used okay i'm i'm i'm selling it
really well
but you probably want to wash it because
it it's been lying around i found it in
my carpet you know recently and it's
been lying around for a long time so it
looks a little it looks a little iffy
but just wash it i never i never wore it
okay
all right um good so um do we have more
yes sir
is
so you're saying do we follow the single
responsibility principle here or
[Music]
i'm not sure i understand the question
here
yes i'm sorry i i you kind of lost me
there i'm sorry maybe you know if you
find another way of putting you tweet me
or write me an email or something like
that i'll be happy to to to help you out
if it just
can i apply that rules to the to classes
as well
um yeah i think you can you know that i
tried to do a couple of illustrations
with that where we looked at you know we
start by looking at the startup class
for example and saying you know at that
level of abstraction just looking at the
public api of a class does that look
like it's it's sort of a coherent thing
i tend to not that much you know
look at that you know i'm more
interested in looking at methods of
functions um
because sometimes i think uh you know i
have i have a couple of examples in the
book where i have a class that actually
turns out to have like seven or eight
members um but each of those members are
fairly self-contained so you can sort of
you can almost imagine that you can
slice them up and and you know
understand each what each of them does
without understanding any of the other
ones um
it's mostly analysis mechanism analysis
method i that i use to to look at you
know the actual code in terms of
implementation i have you know in the
book uh and in the workshop i also hold
you know that i give based on the book i
have a lot of other design principles uh
where i talk about you know what's a
good design principles in terms of api
design and you know what how do you
design uh interfaces and classes and so
on
and they go hand in hand pretty well but
it's not quite this way of looking at it
it's sort of complementary to that
but if you would like the book should
you would like one all right thank you
okay so i am i'm out of giveaways um but
that doesn't mean that i'm not you know
i'm absolutely happy to take more
questions uh i'm also mindful of your
time um
but we we actually do have 10 more
minutes so if you want to have questions
then
feel free to ask if you want to get
ahead and out of the room before
everyone else i can completely
understand that as well so
any more questions
yes sir
right yeah okay so the question is i
talked a little bit about haskell and
how it distinctly distinguishes between
pure and impure code so what's my
personal opinion opinion on why is
haskell not more popular that's that's
your question right
um
no i'm just making sure that i verify
phrase you will because i think people
in the back probably couldn't hear you
and because i have the microphone you
don't
it's not not your fault at all um
haskell is a wonderful language but it's
also really difficult to learn
and i think you could probably do things
to make it easier to learn but the way
that haskell is often being taught uh it
sort of um
puts a lot of people off
and it's also you know if you the way
that that you often teach
haskell it's probably a little bit
difficult to understand if you're you
know beginner programmer it's a little
bit hard to understand why do we need to
jump through all these
strange you know language constructs in
order to achieve simple things you know
um
just if you want to do simple i o right
to the console right to disk and so on
there's actually a lot of machinery here
that you have to understand in haskell
in order to do simple things things that
you know in other languages will just be
you know console.writeline um so if you
um and you're often you know beginners
are often impatient they just want to
learn and get things to working and
haskell sort of you know very
deliberately prevents you from having
things that
that works basically um
so so i think that's that's that's one
reason uh
i i actually wish that it would it would
be much more useful um or much more used
in in the industry but it's not and i
don't think it will will be but it's a
wonderful thinking tool
um i i basically um i've worked so much
with haskell now that i tend to think in
haskell when i when i problem solve
and then i when i've sort of thought
things through and maybe a little done a
little prototype and haskell then i
would go and re-implement the things in
if chavo and xi shot instead
so i definitely if you're interested in
functional programming i would you know
recommend that everyone sooner or later
learns haskell because it's it really it
really gives you an insight into one
functional programming is that no other
language will give you
um so for that reason i think it's
really important but um
only if you're interested because it
would it will require significant
investment of your time and i think also
that's why it's not more popular
so i hope that's the best answer i can
give you uh and i i don't want to tire
anyone else with rambling on so we can
always talk about that you know if you
if you want to talk about this more than
you know
find me in the break and we i'm happy to
discuss this more anyone else
i'm quite blinded by these things and
it's a it looks like there's no more
questions which means that you get out
of here six minutes before time isn't
that wonderful
so thanks for coming and i hope you have
a great conference
[Applause]
you